bonsoir bonsoir heureuse d'être là alors
aujourd'hui frédéric et moi nous allons
échanger autour de deux activités qui
font partie de votre vie quotidienne
depuis votre plus tendre enfance un
tellement partie de vous même que sans
doute vous y réfléchissez même pas on va
parler aujourd'hui de lecture et
d'écriture
pas une journée pendant laquelle vous ne
lisez pas pas une journée sans doute
pendant laquelle vous n'écrivez pas et
c'est sans doute un fils qui vous
conduira tout au long de vos jours
quelles que soient les chemins que vous
empruntez alors bien sûr la lecture et
l'écriture se matérialise dans des voies
tout à fait différente on écrit un texto
on lit un magazine on prend des notes
[Musique]
on
ou lit ses notes on écrit des mots
d'amour et on les lit et plus parfois
aussi on peut lire ou écrire lire et
écrire de la littérature
alors la littérature c'est un grand mot
ça peut être inhibant rassurez vous
notre idée aujourd'hui n'est
certainement pas de tenter de définir
tous à de décortiquer les choses mais
plutôt d'échanger autour du plaisir que
cela apporte la littérature elle n'est
jamais là où l'on pense la trouver lé
chemin
l es rencontres elle est mise en
mouvement et je suis heureuse d'échangés
aujourd'hui avec toi frédéric parce que
depuis que je te connais ça fait un bon
moment mais je trouve que tu incarnes
bien cette idée de mettre en mouvement
frédéric et comédienne metteuse en scène
cinéaste elle écrit des poèmes des
romans des récits tu pars mais aussi aux
mots des autres d'advenir au sein des
ateliers d'écriture que tu animes et
puis tu tu entretiens avec des créateurs
d'horizons très différents de jaco van
dormael à isabelle stengers au sein de
cette collection orb que tu as créé aux
éditions esperluette et que tu animes
alors il me semble pour commencer cet
entretien que le lieu où se rassemblent
toutes ces vies que le lieu où les
choses se tissent et se tricote c'est
précisément le texte j'avais envie de
t'entendre là dessus je vais m'entendre
parler du texte arrive en plein siècle
dans la ville à milan go et risque parce
qu'ils me ce qui me vient comme ça c'est
peut-être justement la place du texte
ans dans le quotidien tout cas dans le
dans le mien ce choix ce choix d'écrire
et le rapport qu'on peut entretenir avec
avec un texte pour moi un texte c'est
une matière
déjà c'est pas quelque chose qui est
défini c'est un univers de possibles
c'est une matière qu'on peut travailler
et retravailler à souhait et qui va avec
lesquels je vais échanger en fait je
vais pas aller jusqu'au bout de mon idée
là maintenant mais avec
avec lequel je vais entretenir un
rapport voilà donc un le texte paraît
sentent quelque chose de vivant
je sais pas si je réponds à la question
oui chacun de tes textes le rapport ou
encore aux sensations aux émotions est
toujours quelque chose de très présent
or on sait tous combien c'est une chose
compliquée à mettre en mots on peut
manquer sa cible
on peut ne pas sonner juste et je lisais
ce propos un petit texte d'un auteur qui
nous est chère à toutes les deux on en
parlait encore tout à leur série des
loups car grand romancier grand
romancier italien qui avait cette
formule que je trouvais assez éclairante
il dit souvent ça clapote il n'y a pas
de vie y a pas de vérité ainsi oublier
aussitôt que lui et puis il poursuit en
disant souvent ça clapote mais parfois
ça crépite
et ben voilà le crépitement c'est cette
arrivée de la lumière de la vie de
l'envié du désir
je voulais savoir comment tu faisais
pour que ça crépite parce que tes textes
crépitent
ouais enfin j'utilise ce mot vivant tout
à l'heure mais c'est justement ça c'est
de tenter de mettre en mots au plus
juste ce qui m'habite donc ce que je
porte en moi donc c'est un c'est un
travail on dit trouver le mot juste ma
main c'est un peu un lieu commun mais
c'est saidal et ses dauphins de
d'entretenir avec le monde une relation
d'alliance en fait ce sont des alliés et
de les laisser parler de les laisser se
montre et des vivres et possiblement de
les laisser entrer en résonance avec eux
voilà donc ensuite c'est un travail
c'est à dire qu'on souvent on a
l'impression qu'on est maître des mots
et il ya peut-être un sentiment de toute
puissance
à ce moment là et ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose que que j'espère éviter
parce que ça c'est le piège
et c'est là que je ne trouverai pas le
mot allié le mot juste le mot vivant
alors par rapport aux crépitements j'ai
envie de rebondir quand même par rapport
par rapport à ça parce qu'on peut faire
le lien avec le texte peut parler de
crépitement comme si vous imaginez les
flots la rivière la mer quelque chose de
pas être joli scintillant et d'ondulants
surface et puis en dessous il ya du
mouvement
il ya des courants s'est froissé chaud
mais c'est ça bouge et je pense que pour
moi un texte c'est ne peut être abouti
d'un blizzard moment fin on va dire ne
peut tenir debout qu'à partir du moment
où il y a en même temps cette forme qui
peut être peut-être un peu un peu
d'apparence lice esthétique mais qui en
dessous il y ait du mouvement dans
quelque chose qui va qui va me mettre en
mouvement
aussi bien dans la lecture aussi bien
dans l'écriture et ça ce sont les roches
ce sont les sables qui bouge sont les
montagnes qui s'écroule mais s'il n'y a
pas de mouvement il n'y a pas de vie et
donc c'est vraiment important dans la
dans la fabrication dans le tissage d'un
texte de bien de bien garder sa de bien
envisager sa et de bien vivre ça même si
c'est bouleversant
même si ça demande beaucoup de travail
de pouvoir générer une matière texte un
texte une forme texte qui soit qu'ils
soient vivantes
oui sinon c'est lisse et c'est ennuyeux
quand on a un texte sur son établi quels
qu'ils soient ont pensé à toutes les
formes d'écriture possible quand on a un
texte sur l'établi il faut jouer avec
beaucoup de contraintes
le vocabulaire et la grammaire bien sûr
mais aussi le poids des conventions le
poids des références culturelles
toi tu dis écrire c'est danser avec ce
client
je trouve que c'est une formule qui est
très forte et je voulais savoir comment
tu faisais au quotidien pour te
débarrasser de tous et on doit il faut
de tout c'est toutes ces normes comment
tu travailles et l'audace la réponse est
pratiquement dans la question
j'ai justement ces bacs et les on doit
il faut non on a tous une histoire une
histoire qui nous fabrique et qui nous
met en rapport en lien avec le texte
avec l'écriture d'une certaine façon
j'ai juste que pour la majorité d'entre
nous avec un millier un parcours
scolaire à une histoire scolaire et bien
c'est en tout cas ce qui me concerne se
mettre tout ça de côté jir c'est faire
fi de ce que j'ai appris et de
redécouvrir chaque fois les possibles
les outils de l'écriture oui pour ne pas
tomber dans cet espace où je vais être
dans la reproduction de ce que j'ai
appris c'est à dire répondre à ce qu'on
a attendu deux mois un résultat avec des
demandes bien précises et qui ont kim
ont fabriqués donc je peux témoigner
qu'il a fallu déconstruire cela et si on
parle des ateliers cripure puisque tu en
a parlé
là tout de suite c'est un des points les
plus fragiles un des points les plus
sensibles
c'est cette déconstruction là c'est de
pouvoir dire ok je lâche je lâche ce que
j'ai appris je suis là et je vais faire
avec ceux qui se montrent ce qu'ils se
montrent deux mois mais ceux qui se
montrent dans ce qui émerge de moi et
apprendre interagir avec ça de façon à
possiblement trouvé son écriture
sinon ça n'a aucun intérêt j'irai on
peut tous écrire de la même façon toi tu
es libre tu peux bien en parler des
livres en tout cas des ouvrages qui sont
formatés qui sont construits ils sont
modélisés mais beaucoup de vrai ça prend
une place importante
1 et là la lecture de fiction je trouve
c'est quelque chose qui vraiment élargi
la vie et c'est ce qui fait le sens
aussi de
de métiers comme les nôtres qui sont
dans le rapport au texte
c'est que le la fiction est un lieu de
d'audace comme comme tu le disais mais
aussi un endroit on apprend à éprouver
soi même
l'empathie la générosité le il ya cette
phrase d'isabelle stengers qui nous a
guidés quand même préparé cet entretien
qui dit apprendre à raconter des
histoires sont vaincus des vérités qui
s'enchevêtrent sans se nier mais c'est
vrai que ça fait qu'aux non seulement à
ton chemin d'écriture en particulier
dans ce roman là où l'eau touchent là où
je trouve que cette phrase est parfaite
en exergue du livre parce qu'elle est
elle ramasse tout tout tout on travaille
c'est une phrase qui m'a aussi renvoyé à
ma propre pratique de lecture je pense
que le lire ce n'est pas comme on peut
le penser en lieu de repli sur soi c'est
au contraire un lieu on va frotter ce
qu'on en est avec ce qu'on n'est pas et
que forcément ceux qu'on ait va s'en
trouver transformer et que moi par
exemple je viens de j'ai fait des études
d'histoire
je suis convaincu que je peux lire dire
bouquin d'historiens très solide très
bien fait sur l' esclavage dans le sud
des états unis
ça va rester quelque chose qui m'ait
extérieur que par contre si je lis un
roman de toni morrison je vais être une
esclave noir dans une plantation du sud
des états unis et je pense que ça il ya
que la fiction qui peut qui peut faire
ça dans ce livre par exemple d'en parler
il ya un personnage de big g projet
prouve ce que cette fille ressent cette
fille qu'on ne laisse jamais terminer
ses phrases c'est le poids de
l'humiliation qu'elle ressent on
l'éprouvé je pense que ça élargit notre
spectre d'émotions notre spectre de dans
la relation aux autres et que donc la
lecture n'est pas un endroit personnel
c'est au contraire l'endroit où on se
frotte au monde on se frotte aux autres
au monde
je crois que
que la lecture mais l'écriture aussi
c'est un lieu de poissy vont parler
d'utopie tout à l'heure donc c'est comme
un endroit un espace de prolongation de
création mais de prolongation et qui
nous transforme cas qui me transforme
écrire et lire
c'est une exigence que j'ai si ça ne me
met pas en travail up poubelles fait
dire ça ne m'intéresse pas de mettre au
travail ça veut dire un jour jouer mes
montagnes mêmes et fonds marins la de
tout à l'heure j'ai quelque part ça va
bouger quelque chose ça va questionner
et le questionnement n'est pas
uniquement mental intellectuel
encyclopédique
oui il est aussi très intime il est dans
la dent de l'ordre de la profondeur et
ça ce sont des choses qui nous échappent
qui m'échappe et que je vais pouvoir
peut-être découvrir dans un mois dans un
an
comme disait bérénice c'est un rapport
au texte qui est assez singulier pour
toi le texte n'est certainement pas un
produit c'est au contraire une matière
vivante
oui oui je sais je pense que c'est
important dans la dans la dans
l'apprentissage même de l'écriture de ne
jamais envisagé le texte ou la
production de matières texte comme un
résultat le résultat on a toujours un
mais mais comme un processus et donc
c'est ça que je tente de vous raconter
c'est que c'est par le biais du
processus même qui a transformation la
transformation s'opère et que parce que
le processus existe et que je ne vais
pas écrire en pensant un résultat à ce
qu'on attend de moi
aux regards extérieurs même aux lecteurs
en tout cas dans un premier temps que je
vais pouvoir me interagir et continuer à
interroger que cette matière jusqu'au
moment où ce texte n'appelle plus où ce
texte il dit ok je suis
je suis debout et possiblement selon
l'âge du banquet va vite à vis mon vieux
beau monde quoi tu collabores avec le
fait que jacques collaborer avec le
texte merci déposer ce mot là parce
qu'il est il est important de ne pas se
positionner comme j'utilisais 7
cette formule de toute-puissance de ne
pas se positionner comme un créateur
tout puissant j'ai le texte
je collabore avec mais je collabore avec
moi qu'il me donne des choses il me
donne des choses ils m'offrent des
choses et il d'abord f1 est très
certainement il est là comme un univers
de possible donc
waouh quoi et le texte est aussi un lieu
de réfléchit beaucoup sur l'écriture
collaborative et le et c'est aussi une
démarche assez singulière mais une qui
ouvre beaucoup de qui activent beaucoup
de mes possibilités
oui 6 non pas le cas on revient cette
collaboration
l'écriture collaborative elle est très
intéressante parce que de l'écriture
copains collaborative on peut opérer un
glissement sur d'autres d'autres types
de créations communes mais ça implique
de pouvoir apprendre à penser ensemble
faire ensemble de se mettre en tant
qu'auteur de côté au profit du texte à
dire c'est le texte qui est au centre
oui et quand tu vois le texte comme un
espace de collaboration tu as qu
aussitôt rapport à l'éditeur attend même
pour booster bien une question qui est
toujours une question un peu tarte à la
crème pour les grands lecteurs leur dis
toujours à et sinon restez quand quel
est le livre que vous emporteriez sur
une île déserte mais j'ai l'impression
qu'un écrivain je m'arrête si je me
trompe mais on est content a déjà
demandé qu eric écririez vous sur une
île déserte
j'ai l'impression que robinson il
n'écrit pas que pour qu'un texte
advienne il faut pas seulement qui est
un auteur que le texte ne n'est que s'il
ya par l'autre pour l'autre avec l'autre
parce que le lecteur existe un moment
donné mais je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec la fin je mettrais nuance
néanmoins j'ai on peut écrire pour soi
et c'est important de se voir sage et on
peut écrire pour soi et ses riches aussi
l'or sur une île déserte
effectivement je me dis ben je vois 2
juillet jamais pensé mais mais mais
j'écris tout le temps dans ma tête donc
c'est un peu comme un tour sur une île
déserte s'agit pas seulement d'avoir du
papier ou une plage de sable écrire sur
le sable mouillé une belle image comme
ça mais oui on écrit dans sa tête on
sera content
1 je me raconte des histoires et le
texte fabrique il ya une maturation on
fait vraiment un truc comme ça qu'ils
quinet qui pousse qui grandit et puis à
mon année c'est le bon moment c'est beau
moment de tenter doucement avec respect
de mettre les mots les mots à
l'extérieur de moi peut-être pour les
autres c'est toute la générosité de ta
démarche
j'espère j'espère merci merci merci à
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]